Um uh I I don't really have any
resources to do that right now.
>> We have limited funds and so we tend to
help those that have are part of the
church or come to the church.
>> Um we really don't have an estimated
time just because we do receive a lot of
requests here. Um each applicant is
different. [crying] Um it can take a
couple days, it can take a couple weeks.
We really just don't have a time frame
there. Uh, we can, ma'am. Uh, where do
you where do you live? You live in
Charlottes.
>> Yes, I'm like 10 minutes from you all.
>> Yeah, that's fine, man. If you come over
here, remove.
>> Okay.
>> Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Asalamaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends,
hope you guys are well in. So, we're
going to be reacting to a amazing epic
experiment and subhan Allah. In this
experiment, something came to mind and I
was like, subhan Allah, not many people
picked it up. The experiment is of a
woman. I don't know if she's a
Christian. I think she's a Christian or
maybe not a believer or anything. She
decides to call up 30 churches. Amongst
those uh 30 numbers, if I'm not
mistaken, is a mosque and a temple and I
think and two Catholic churches which
are predominantly black. So here's what
happens. Let's watch a video because
it's so profound because you see the
Christian fundamentalists always talking
about, you know, abortion, abortion,
abortion, abortion, human life, human
life, abortion, don't kill babies,
abortion. Some of them radical u um
fundamentalist they even actually attack
uh abortion centers even like you know
if I'm saying there wasn't a bomb or
something like that for that matter. So
they are very very severe with that. But
when it comes to this the experiment
shows that they were saying no and it's
like said you're against abortion
because life is important but that when
that baby is given birth to you refuse
feeding it. It's hypocrisy. It's
religious hypocrisy. You say something
and don't do it. And Allah says in the
Quran as Muslims Allah says in the Quran
it is hateful in the sight of God that
you say something that which you don't
do. It's hypocrisy. So this is something
that is absolutely unacceptable. But
here is the video. Let's watch for
ourselves. And some other people have
also done the experiment. But it is so
epic and it shows how important. And we
as Muslims, we practice what we preach.
The whole world has made us to be v
vilified, terrorists. We're this or
that, etc., whatever. But in reality,
the whole world has woken up to what the
true evil of Zionism and their belief
system is. And sadly, a lot of
Christians, not to all. Alhamdulillah,
Islam is always showing us, subhan
Allah, that how we practice what we
preach. Here's the video, inshallah.
Let's get to it.
>> Uh I I don't really have any resources
to do that right now. The account where
I have to give to community members.
>> No, we don't help with formula at all.
Have you talked to anybody like at CCC?
>> Yeah, I've been calling everywhere all
day.
>> Oh, okay. Uh we are a small church and
uh as a result our go we have limited
funds and so we tend to help those that
are part of the church or come to the
church.
>> Um we really don't have an estimated
time just because we do receive a lot of
requests here. Um each applicant is
different. [crying] Um it could take a
couple days, it could take a couple
weeks. We really just don't have a time
[crying] frame there.
Okay. You said it would take a couple
days to weeks.
>> Yes, ma'am. Yeah, if approved.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you.
>> Hasn't ate all day and she I like I
don't know what else to do.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm not sure cuz we don't have
cash here and I'm I'm not control
finances.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, and we don't we don't
have anything either. So, I'm sorry. I
wish I had something to to offer you.
>> What you mean a baby formula?
>> Yeah, I have a
>> You want You want somebody to give you
some money or something?
>> No, I just need the formula. I have a
two-month-old and she ran out last
night, so she's went all night and all
day without formula.
>> Yeah, we don't have any formula here for
baby. No, we have a kitchen, but we
don't have milk.
>> Okay. Is there any way y'all could just
get a can and I could pick it up?
>> No, I don't know. We don't have time to
do that because
They have a church and they won't even
[singing]
>> ma'am. Where do you where do you live?
>> Yes. I'm like 10 minutes from you all.
>> Okay. Uh and what kind of formula?
[crying]
>> It's the good start.
>> Good start. Um
>> yeah that's fine ma'am if you come over
here you
>> okay um hold on just
>> okay guys so the video that we saw now
you can see that she's calling these
churches she's literally has a baby
crying in the background so she's trying
to make it more dramatic and make it
like you know my baby's starving look
even if the church doesn't have the
funds you cannot come and tell me an
individual whoever is said you don't
have what $20 you said you do not have
$20 to give it just shows when the
religion when its foundation is
corrupted and it's not ba based on true
belief. Yes, it's it's it's the the
followers are going to be the same and
I'm not saying now every single
Christian is that of course not there
are some really amazing lovely
Christians that I've met myself. So
everyone in that category is not fair
but this shows a growing issue and a
problem. Now this is an experiment that
we saw. Subhan Allah. And the moment she
calls a mosque you saw her reaction. The
moment they call, she calls the first
mosque. The first question they ask is,
"We don't have formula, but we can give
you money to get it." Yes. Which means
that even if the mosque didn't have the
funds, which it does. I'm sure it does.
No matter what it is, come on. $20. Come
on, get out of here. Yeah. Somebody will
give it. And that's why in Islam, we are
told
means a a a voluntary um charity. There
is charity that's obligatory on the
Muslims, which is 2.5%. But there's also
sodak. Saddak is something that's highly
rewarded that subhan Allah God Almighty
says when a individual soul in the Quran
is taken when they have they have died
and see the unseen they say they will
say to Allah to God Almighty please send
me back to do what to pray no to go Hajj
pilgrimage no to fast no to do what
obedience to parents no send me back so
I can give in charity and Allah tells us
that evildoers those who are evil
towards the poor people and do not help
the poor people hellfire is their place.
So, it shows us great emphasis on that.
Now, there is another video of another
individual carrying out the same social
experiment. Let's watch that.
>> I'm wondering if you guys can provide
with one can of formula.
>> Sure. You can come in to the when are
you around the class? You can stop by
today. Maybe you can help you to buy it.
>> Let's call a mosque in Dearborn and see
if they will give baby formula. I'm
going to mention that I'm not Muslim to
see if it changes anything. We're going
to try Islamic Institute of America on
Ford Road.
>> Islamic Institute of America.
>> Um,
>> I I wanted to ask, can you guys provide
just one can of baby formula? I ran out
and I'm short on
um for my baby.
>> Hey, let me Okay, let me let me double
check. What's your phone number? 313.
>> What's your name?
>> Padia.
>> How much is it?
>> $30.
>> Okay. I'll double check and get back
with you. Okay.
>> Okay. Thank you so much.
>> Okay. Bye-bye. You're welcome.
>> So, we're going to try Islamic House of
Wisdom. And I hope she doesn't call back
while I'm on this call.
>> I'm so sorry. Islamic House of Wisdom.
Hi, I have a question.
>> Go ahead.
>> Um um uh I'm short on baby formula for
my baby and I'm wondering if you guys
can provide with one can of formula.
>> Sure. You can come in to the when are
you around close? You could stop by
today. Maybe can help you to buy it
because we don't have actually formula
here but we can give you money to buy
it. Oh, and is it okay that I'm not
Muslim?
>> That's fine.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Will you be coming in? So, so I can tell
the receptionist just in case I'm not
here to expect you.
>> Uh, I wanted to say thank you. I'm
making a video and I just wanted to see
if you guys would help. Like, thank you
so much. I don't need it.
>> You're welcome.
>> That was so sweet. Thank you.
>> Oh, no problem. Thank you. Good luck.
>> Bye.
>> Bye. Islamic House of Wisdom, Dearborn
Heights. I feel so bad.
Like some moms actually need this. I
feel so guilty right now.
>> No. No.
>> While we wait.
>> So you can see that. And not only that,
brothers and sisters, subhan Allah, she
actually goes away by saying, "If I'm
not here, I'll make sure someone they're
literally going out their way." And this
is what we believe from my sisters that
when we help somebody, Allah tells us in
the Quran that when you help a poor or
someone in need, say that I'm only
helping you for the sake of God, I do
not expect any reward or or anything
from you like I do not want anything
from you. And this is a principle that
applies across board. If I have a friend
who is in debt and I give him that
money, I don't give him that money with
the intentions of oh, I'll lend him
money today and tomorrow he might lend
me money or I'll do him a favor today.
So no, because that's transactional. It
should be done purely for the sake of
God. That even if that person you give
the money to spat at you, swore at you,
insulted you, tried to attack you, you
do not regret doing that deed because it
was not done for like transactional but
for the sake of God. And you know what's
interesting? She even called a mega
church which is owned by Charlie was
owned by Charlie Kirk. And come on, they
get millions of pounds. Guess what? They
did not give it to her. That is
sickening. That to me is sickening
because Charlie Kirk, I'm not blaming
him. He's a man who's died. Yes, he's
dead. So, but what principles did he
leave those that church with? That
multi-million pound church. Yes. 20,000
people attend or congregations and they
could not even give a $30 baby milk
formula. Unbelievable. And subhan Allah,
you ring the churches and different
example. This is another one that we
just quickly watch. Inshallah.
>> Sure. You can come into the win around
the other. can stop by today. Maybe you
can help sell to you to buy it cuz you
don't have actually formula here, but we
can give you money to buy it.
>> Oh, and is it okay that I'm not Muslim?
>> That's fine.
>> We don't have baby formula, but we can
give you the money for you to go buy it.
Can you imagine churches saying that?
Maybe they have. And I'm wrong. I don't
know. I haven't seen every video.
>> And there was a statement of Charlie
Clerk saying Islam is not in line with
the Western values. I agree with him.
Islam and Western values are two
opposite things because the Islamic
values does not say that you can go to
other people's countries, bomb millions
of people, steal their resources.
Alhamdulillah. Islamic values doesn't
say that you can have places of gambling
that you rob people's money, cause some
of them for suicide and destroy houses.
Islam does not say we promote alcoholism
and drugs so people can lose their lives
and lose their loved ones. Islam doesn't
promote sex outside of marriage that
degrades a woman to be a mere sexual
object, a mere inanimate object.
Alhamdulillah. Islam is there to promote
good. And that's why I 100% agree with
Charlie Kirk. Islam and the Western
values are two opposites. Alhamdulillah.
And Islam is the has the moral high
ground and we are morally consistent not
strategically. So for all of those
Islamophobes that's why and this is an
important message Allah does not need us
to give dawa. This shows that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala will get a
disbeliever. Yes, a someone that doesn't
believe in Islam to do a experiment like
this and it's gone so viral that people
will flock to Islam. And this is a
reminder that we need Allah. Allah does
not need us. And Allah subhanaa tala
will help and will bring thousands if
not millions of people to Islam and
Islam is a fast growing religion and the
enemies hate that and subhan Allah you
know why because we practice what we
preach. So alhamdulillah brothers
sisters share this video far and wide
inshallah may Allah subhanaa tala guide
that woman to Islam and let this be a
means that she sees the beauty of Islam
and everyone that's watching this that
Islam is the beautiful religion and it
is the truth and it has true monism that
the worship of one God. We don't believe
in any idol worship. God is not a man or
a woman or a son or a daughter or a
father or a mother. There is nothing
like God. He's one and unique. The Quran
is the only scripture that hasn't been
altered that hasn't been changed. The
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him has
miracles and prophecies that have come
to be. He is the true prophet. We urge
you guys to study Islam inshallah. Till
next time.